joining me now for reaction is
Republican congressman Bob Goodlatte who
is the chairman at the House Judiciary
Committee and is co-sponsoring his own
immigration bill congressman here we are
again
I mean gang of eight disaster Bush Bush
Schumer went down in flames like 1200
pages the McCain Bush disaster back in
2006-2007 another killer for you know
for Republicans your view here well
Laura we have control over the house you
have control of the Senate we have the
White House why would we turn that
control back over to the Democrats and
have another fiasco like the ones that
you just described it's important to
address this issue but this issue is how
we're going to secure our borders close
the loopholes like the asylum loophole
that you just described and there are
many others and make sure that people
have confidence that their government
will keep them safe in their communities
and along the border of this country
that's what the legislation that I along
with Mike McCaul chairman of the
Homeland Security Committee Raul
Labrador chair of the immigration
subcommittee martha mcsalley chairman
the border somebody came up with and it
does address the daca situation in a
fair way but only in exchange for making
sure that we don't let this problem
continue in the future
so in this in this discharge petition
madness I mean people hear that so like
their eyes are glazing over I'm sure but
it's really important because weird
stuff can happen with a discharge
petition as you know it wouldn't end
catch-and-release it looks like they
wouldn't have any catch and release they
wouldn't end the chain migration all
these things that are multiplier effects
on illegal immigration and immigration
amnesty in this country massive
increases in legal immigration
none of it would be effective well the
risk is you'll get an unbalanced bill
where you address daca and none of these
are other things and 180 hundred ninety
Democrats would join with 30 or 40
Republicans and pass something that the
overwhelming majority of House
Republicans and the majority of American
people and certainly the Republican base
would not be satisfied with because it
wouldn't address the problem but
congressman congressman Kabelo said a
discharge petition is precisely the way
to get the
done let's watch no one here is
interested in a spectacle we are
interested in having a debate we're
actually interested in answering the
president's call to action in September
of last year when he challenged Congress
to come up with a bipartisan solution to
this immigration question this discharge
petition process is probably the most
constructive ever because we're not
bringing forward one bill we're offering
the opportunity for four bills to come
to including one that's backed by
immigration hardliners and another that
would be drafted and filed by the
Speaker of the House the answer is he
should work with the Republican
leadership and with the committee the
Judiciary Committee to produce one bill
that Republicans get behind and the
president can sign into law our chairman
Goodlatte thank you so much